هذه الصور
تظهر استهداف
للمنطاد الصيني طبعا هناك امور فنيه تتعلق
بشرح هذه الصوره ما الذي يحدث كيف ستتم
عمليه استهدافه واسقاطه يبدو انها صواريخ
على ما يبدو من الصوره
لاسقاطه
الصوره تظهر فيها هذه
الاشارات الخاصه بالتحرك او ان تمت ما يتم
في محيط هذه المنطقه ليست المساله واضحه
ولكن هذه الصور ربما تظهر وفقا للاعلام
الامريكي استهداف للمنطقه الصيني لاسقاطه
من سماء كارولينا الجنوبيه هذه الصور كانت
التقطت منذ قليل وقام الاعلام الامريكي
ببثها ونشرها منذ قليل
سيد ايهاب
وفقا لبعض التقديرات العلميه في هذا الامر
انه حتى ولو تم استهدافه لاسقاطي ربما
يحتاج الامر الى وقت الاتمام هذه العمليه
هناك ايضا بعض البيانات الامريكيه التي
اشارت الى انه سيتم تجميع حطامه حتى تتم
اختبارات معينه